wow you better get her because you know
this will get real left no you're real
quick i think she's the only one who has
you real quick
very nice real quick shout out and
bilal's ex-wife shahida go at it
southeast daigo will be up in here
[Music]
what was supposed to be a meeting to
peacefully reconcile their differences
y'all it gets so bad below starts to
pray during the argument
oh no shahidah
why did we have to go there
let's get into it
hey 90 day fans fam it's melisia all
right i have to make this recap quick
because i'm headed out of town but i
didn't want to leave without us having a
conversation about this argument between
shaida and shahidah
by the way just a follow-up from last
week's recap so you're in the loop
smith's mom continues her fit this
episode she disowned him last week after
he told her he secretly married jenny
and this week she told him he can't come
to her funeral
she banned her son from coming to her
funeral she told him he can't go to his
dad's either
is making huge sacrifices for the sake
of love and his mom i mean
it just seems like she thinks of the
worst things to say
that's tough
i'm not the type to be dealing with any
baby mama drama all right on to shaida
and bilal
these two are meeting up with his
ex-wife shahida
with hopes of hashing out the issues
that are going on between them if you
need a refresher shadow feels as if she
deserves an apology from shahidah
i have to know that
you know you're not here for just what
he has for how she spoke to her when she
visited the house to inquire about
shaida signing a prenup you know the
kids have been here yeah i have been
here shahida definitely insanity that i
am here for the wrong reasons like i'm
here to take what bilal has on the other
hand at the tell-all shahida reveals
that she wants an apology from shaida
and bilal when the truth is revealed
he'll owe me an apology she will too for
what
i don't know
i'm pretty worried about the meeting
with my ex-wife
just on the right here scheidak had like
a defensive demeanor about herself
shahida shows up at the restaurant with
no intention to apologize to shaida last
meeting that i had with falau he told me
that i overstepped
the friendship bound with shaida
i was just
trying to look out for his well-being
and his best interests as well as the
kids
[Music]
apologizing for what
i knew right after that moment that this
was not going to go well how's
everything going with people
i'm good and we're just looking forward
to like meeting you again hopefully on
pleasant tims once shahida gets to the
table shaida lets her know that she felt
disrespected when shahida came to her
home
okay
what did i say to make you hurt and
upset i think it's not what you say
about how you said it
you were very much aggressive you had a
lot of reach
uh scheida um shaykira
did i yell at you
no but it sounds like you're about to
shata points out to shahida that the
same tone she's using right now
i'm not about to sit here and stand for
that because that's not what i did it's
the same energy she approached her with
at the house bilal tries to get through
to his ex by telling her that just
because you think what you said wasn't
hurtful doesn't mean that it didn't hurt
shaida
people take things in different ways
it's like you came
ranting and raving i was just like
standing in the kitchen like
i don't want her coming back like i was
like ready to ban you from my home it's
like she can't come back here and behave
like that
ben me from my home from your home yeah
okay
shahid is probably thinking
i would come to that house before bilal
even knew you
and you're going to ban me
but
shada is his wife now
and that is her home i think that you
know
um
what was done could have been done a lot
better you know
came at you know my wife uh
you know set up again
you guys are
you know grown adults you know and
it shouldn't be any
bad blood between either one of y'all
like i don't want it to be like bad
blood between us i was looking to
get to know you have a good relationship
with you i was actually hoping for us to
like be cordial with each other like i
wanted us to be compatible for the sake
of the kids but i just wanted to
acknowledge the fact that when you came
inside my home
you came at rich you were not cordial
you were not polite
that's all i want you to like
acknowledge it the truth is
people apologize all the time when they
don't want to for peace sake it's not
the end of the world
all shihita has to say is shaida my
intention was not to disrespect you but
if it came off that way
i apologize
simple
but now sometimes our pride gets in the
way
i'm not going to apologize for something
that i didn't do then why did you come
here
i came here to actually
clear the air but i'm not apologizing
for it i'm telling you i'm literally
done vlad you better get her because you
know this will get real no you better
get caught it's already gone left
southeast dango will be up in here so
what yeah you know someone's about to
turn up when they start calling out
where they're from
southeast dango will be up in here so
what i don't know and don't say
something don't say something cause you
don't have to listen you're putting on
me that did not happened
to be honest i wish i had more time to
discuss my thoughts but for a number of
reasons
this argument bothers me these are two
women who are capable of having a
healthy conversation it didn't have to
go down this route i'm not really
concerned with who's at fault with
things going left real quick this will
get real no you
but overall i think it's unfortunate
that it has to turn out this way you
need to watch who you're talking to okay
be quiet for a second please can i say
something and i'm not i'm not gonna do
that with her because she don't know me
you don't know me either shahidah you
better get her no because i will reach
across that table and
i don't care go ahead and that's the
conduct you want to conduct yourself as
a muslim woman what kind of example are
you searching for your 16 year old
daughter
that is no example
after shahida leaves shaiden bala get up
to go and he's clearly upset about the
entire matter
i can even put words into my mouth right
now
just the feeling of how things went
i have no idea what's going to happen
now and what's what to do right
when i spoke to below and shadow
recently asked for an update on where
things stand with shahida
here's what they have to say
well we are cordial you know for the
sake of the children you have to be
cordial because sometimes the bigger
picture is you focus on your children so
despite if you're feeling some type of
way you try to put your differences
aside just to be cordial with the person
which i have been you know have been
doing a time you know but at the same
time i am looking at this as oh this is
i'm in a family unit now so for the sake
of the kids i'm for the sake of having a
peaceful family life she and i are
cordial
[Music]
are y'all ready for this below inside of
train
yeah it's gonna be interesting all right
90 day fans fam i won't have a recap for
you next week but i will be back the
following week with everything you need
to know in the meantime make sure you
stick with et because we're covering it
all see you next time